من بيروت ينضم لينا العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه يعني الجانبان الان يتحدثان
عن استهداف البناء التحتيه الجانب الروسي
يقر بانه يستهدف البناء تحتيه انتقاما
والجانب الاوكراني يتحدث عن ذلك ويقول
الروس انه ايضا يصادف البلاد تحتيه
بصواريخ هاي مارس الامريكيه الصنع ما
الهدف المراد تحقيقه عسكريا من استهداف
البنا التحتيه بين الجانبين
زين العابدين اولا اصبحت استراتيجيه
معتمده من قبل روسيا عمليه لكسب الوقت ضرب
البعد البشري والانساني لانه هذا البعد
البشري والانسان يشكل العمق الاستراتيجي
للجبهات التي تقاتل فيها القوات
الاوكرانيه وتحقق نتائج معينه اليوم
استهداف هذه البناء التحتيه والتي لها
علاقه خاصه مياه تدفئه وكهرباء ستخلق ازمه
اجتماعيه ستخلق ازمه ازمه نازحين وهذا امر
قد يضغط على اوروبا اليوم لاول مره زين
العابدين يقول حق احد من تنتج عن انه لم
نعد معارض ان تقصف همم اوكرانيا اهداف
عسكريه داخل روسيه تستعمل لقصف داخل
الاوكراني وهذا يعتبر تحول مهم جدا حتى
حسب القانون الدولي يمكن الرد على الرد و
بالمثل
طيب هذا التطور برايك الى اين سيؤدي ما
الذي يمكن ان نشهده خلال الفتره المقبله
القريبه
الفتره المقبله ليلى هي مرحله او مرحله
تحسين الوضع التكتيكي في مناطق معينه
تحدثت اليوم بالتقرير على الميليتوبول
ميليتو بول جزء مهم جدا ومحوريه في جنوب
اوكرانيا هي الباب الى الدمباس هي الباب
الى القرم هي الباب الى اقليم او ما تبقى
من اقليم خرسان وهي الباب الى زباروجه
والى نرقدار المحطه النوويه المهمه جدا هل
سيجري شيء في المستقبل اليوم الكل يتحدث
عن الشتاء خلال الشتاء يمكن القيام
بعمليات والتحذير له على قدم وساق ولكن لا
يمكن القيام بعمليه مهمه خاصه في الربيع
عند ذوبان الثلوج والجليد حيث يتشكل
العوائق خاصه الوحل
طيب في ما يتعلق
بتصريحات الامريكيه السابقه يعني
التصريحات الامريكيه تحدثت عن ان الحرب
ستبططا لكن ما نشاهده عكس ذلك
يعني مديره الاستخبارات الوطنيه تحدثت عن
هذا الامر بسبب الشتاء وهي قد تكون رساله
لروسيه والرساله لي اوكرانيا ولكن اليوم
في هذه المرحله زي العابدين عند عندما
يبدا الجليد تصبح الحركيه قادره او تسمح
بالحركيه العسكريه ولكن تسمح بالحركيه
العسكريه على الطرقات المعينه والاساسيه
وهذا ما يجعل صعوبه التحرك لانه الحركه
تعتبر عندها اهداف هينه وسهله ولكن لن
تكون بالزخم القابل وهنا تظهر معدله
اساسيه اذا اوكرانيا يتوقف هذا الامر يعطي
وقت روسيه كي تحذر نفسها واذا توقفت روسيه
ايضا يعطي الامر لي اوكرانيا كي تحضر
نفسها ويعتبر رئيس بوتين خاسرا من هنا
اهميه هذه المرحله
ربما من هنا ايضا هذا يساعدنا ان نفهم
تصريحات السفير الاوكراني في المانيا هذا
الحديث عن الحاجه للمزيد من الاسلحه
الانظمه المضاده للطائرات ومدافع المرتزقه
للحديث بهذه الطريقه والحديث عن عدم ضغط
من بلاده ما الذي نقراه في الثنايا
ليلى كل مرحله من المراحل الحرب وهي اربعه
حتى الان باوكرانيا كان هناك السلاح قالب
للمعادلات من سلاح المضاد للدروع بالمرحله
الاولى الى الهيمرس بالمرحله الثانيه هذه
المرحله تتطلب الحرب والعداد اللازم للحرب
خلال الشتاء وخلال الجليد وهنا الاستهداف
البنا التحتيه يحتم حاليا وبطريقه سريعه
حمايه مدافعات او الحمايه الجويه وهذا امر
قد يعتبر صعب نظرا لكبر الاهداف في
اوكرانيا وللمساحه ول- كبرت يعني استهداف
الكثير الكثير من البنا التحتيه شكرا
جزيلا العميد الياس حنا من بيروت دائما
نشكر وجودك معنا والمعلومات التي تزودنا
بها